[Music]
okay who here has been fired from a job
before
i think i have oh no i have for sure
i've never been fired yeah
i uh so i used to work at this
telemarketing company
and you have a headset everyone's in a
cubicle
and the phone just is on automatic dial
and then there's a prompt and then
you're like conducting surveys like hi
ma'am so it says here that you have a
1999 honda crv just want to check on
whatever like that kind of stuff
and this was can i ask you what does
that actually do for your company for
your telemarketer company and was that
your telemarketing voice is that is that
the sales bar voice it sounds so sweet
you sound like a sweetheart i'm like
yeah i'll talk for a little bit
what does it do for the mark the company
yeah yeah they're just hired to conduct
like thousands and thousands of surveys
so they have to just collect those and
then give it back to honda i guess so
it's just data yeah but for me i was in
high school so i was during my like like
raving days so i'm not done raving until
like 5am and then i gotta show up at
work at eight
and then so i'm there and then sometimes
i'm still like in my rave clothes or
sometimes i'm like i just pass out at
the cubicle and then i got like two
warnings and then one time my manner
just came up to me he like he tapped oh
my shoulder was like oh [ __ ] he goes
yeah you should just go home
and uh you don't have to come back
tomorrow and i was like oh [ __ ] i think
i got fired
then you came back the next day
the day after i think i took the hit
yeah and this is during the days where
minimum wage was like seven something
725 or something like that dude nobody
wants to be a telemarketer though you
know dude they're the it's got to be the
worst gig out there it's it must be soul
crushing it must be yeah you call people
sometimes like you know what time it is
it's [ __ ] six o'clock after my family
because i know how i react when i get a
teleporter comedy so i can only imagine
what it's like to be on the other side
[ __ ] hit oh yeah dude i just hang up
yeah
yeah i i try to be as nice as possible i
get surprised when people stay on the
phone though that's me dude i'm too nice
to hang up oh i'm sorry yeah yeah for
sure for sure one of the surveys i
filled out [ __ ] because i was like
[ __ ] man people are hanging up on me and
then i'm like oh yeah my mom gotta see
our feet so i called my mom you
commandantly dialed the number two
that's fine so i surveyed my mom just so
i could fill out because you're supposed
to hit a quota every day i'm like what's
your quota do you remember
you got like three yeah what do you do
if everyone hangs up and in 2021 there's
caller id too you're definitely screwed
don't fire you they're like oh you're
like phone etiquette isn't good enough
to keep people on the phone or something
yeah people are walking up on hello
that's [ __ ] up yeah i would literally
not even care if you say hello i'm
already gone yeah they'll fire you
and with with like robo caller whatever
the [ __ ] app is that tells you you're
done now well they also do this new
thing too where they know what your area
code is and so they'll have an area code
that's your area code when they call you
and so you think maybe it's somebody
that you know and then they got how does
that happen i don't know how do they
just make a phone number or text now
they're texting and you get like group
texts with like business stuff you're
like what the hell is this
there's someone that always says sharika
you need to buy this these miracle
gummies i'm like who is sharika and why
are they sending this to me so weird but
what is a miracle gummy yeah i'm into it
i'll take five pounds
cbd maybe it's always weight loss stuff
for me there was a florida woman who uh
she got fired from her job and they
won't say what the job was
for privacy concerns but she immediately
started to go into her computer her
computer and she started just deleting
all kinds of company records
they said when they came when they some
co-workers after she was fired they saw
her at her desk just hitting the delete
button over and over and over again
and uh so they they got her out of the
the building right right escorted her
out
then she goes home logs into the company
systems keeps deleting [ __ ]
you said you like that you kind of why
it's petty right because it's so pity
yeah it's kind of you can go to jail for
that [ __ ] though you get sued right yeah
i but i also did she clear out the trash
though because people could just go in
and like restore that's the history of
the cookies
what were you saying what do you like
about that that i feel like it probably
wasn't like a huge job
because if she was like you know vp or
something she's probably not going to be
that petty and then it probably wasn't
like your story was just kind of like a
high school gig it's somewhere in
between that's why i think it's kind of
okay
like data entry yeah or something like
this chick is the kind of petty though
where like so one of the instances that
got her fired that helped get her fire
she got into an argument with a fellow
employee
and then she was so [ __ ] pissed about
it that she went back to her desk and
she downgraded their computer access
yeah i like that just to be petty yeah i
like that yeah yeah yeah you can't do
your job oh you want to [ __ ] with me
well now you can't do your job you're
going to get fired yeah
that's hilarious that's smart
would you hire her yeah it's kind of
like like it's kind of like a in inside
white collar crime job but just like a
little you're the worst co-worker no
that's good no i'll leave you we'll get
money motivated though
it's pride motivated it's pettiness
motivated i know i got them yeah and
that feels good yeah and she might not
even know that i stopped your access
all they knew was her
maybe the higher ups but the person that
she blocked might not oh damn i can't
get in this file i can't put my data in
here like damn it sharon
[ __ ] sharon dude
because it's like innocent to me yeah
it's like happening she's not she's not
deleting the nuclear code for our
missile in usa like what the next she's
deleted 17 000 job applications and
resumes
and she left profane messages written in
the system oh that's [ __ ] up that's
kind of funny though yeah i think that's
i think that's the best thing you could
do
well think about the 17 000 people that
applied for the job she kind of [ __ ]
them yeah yeah innocent people
okay dude
okay
okay super power mighty over here
so she was she was um charged for this
uh she
was mike's gonna bail him out though
like community work or something she
ain't going to change yeah around and
hire her it's like it's like i like your
moxie kind of moment one count of
intentionally causing damage to a
protected computer one count of
accessing and protecting computer and
recklessly causing damage she they say
the company spent two years and a
hundred g's creating the computer system
that she wiped out then they had to
spend they're loving it you know that's
buffed up number one
yeah they're [ __ ] lie dude i don't
know you're a huge fan of her do you
mind we'll have a [ __ ] jersey in the
number one
i'm gonna get her chatted
it's like 50k yeah yeah they spent
another 100 g's investigating and
rebuilding it and they say they never
fully recovered the data live she's a
badass delegate
yeah yeah that's absolutely
real [ __ ] programmer i can't delete
anything yeah
how can you even permanently delete
something even if you do the recycle bin
thing it's still there no it's
everywhere it is like if you know how to
do you could restore it so she dragged
it and then she dropped it in the trash
can that's what she did she dragged her
cursor
select it all
dragged it in the trash can i'm glad we
have an expert here thank god
and then she right clicked the trash can
and he said
permanent dude that's what i didn't do
see
that's how they were able to find your
[ __ ] those are tough
computers are tough but it's pretty
obvious that if that happened even if
they could fix it they're gonna say they
couldn't it's just way more money that
yeah did they say what she was charged
with like prison time or money or uh
they were figuring out sentencing but
but just the things i mentioned like
potentially causing damage what's our
next job going to be cia yeah yeah dude
you hear [ __ ] like that though yeah
catch me if you can what happened to
that guy deletes [ __ ] you hear about
[ __ ] like that we like this game never
see the light of day
you're the exact kind of talent that
we're looking
this is my problem with catch me if you
can though
okay you got a guy who lost he got
caught yeah he was caught if you could
at the end yeah yeah
so
get somebody who hasn't gone
[ __ ] caught true that that's an
expert otherwise you're hired failures
bro yeah how do you get someone that is
getting caught i don't know
but getting caught is is is their beacon
it's like oh there's someone that has
this skill but if they're never caught
no one knows that they have it's like
hackers those are the people who are so
[ __ ] good at it that's what i'm
saying but if you catch them too you
could probably blackmail them into doing
good yeah being your job yeah right like
oh we caught you you want to go to jail
joe or you want to work for us that's
the hacker that's what i'm saying that's
that's what the failure he got caught
right i don't want to talk to that guy
what about the uh so how do you even
find the one that can't get caught i
don't know but that's the thing if you
catch someone doing something that you
still can't replicate that's the value
it's like i caught you doing it i don't
know how you did it so you're hired well
how do you even know if the crime's even
happening if you got caught what if it's
not a crime what if it's not a crime
what if it's just something sick like
the uh area 51 dude who like he put like
a rocket
yeah yeah he put like a rock in his
honda or something yep and they're like
all right yeah man come work on some
aliens right so maybe it's not a crime
maybe they're just doing some crazy [ __ ]
but according to steve kai's not that
good he's not that good
lazar
what did he get caught with he's a jason
being focused he got caught with his
friends in the desert looking for ufos
are you talking about yeah with the
rocket with the rocket civic
no he wasn't in the rocket pacific they
had a mobile home out there bro i know
the whole thing got caught being a racer
what do they do in the mobile home yeah
what are they doing out there they're
just they were just chilling having
beers and [ __ ] and watching them
go up that's not illegal they didn't get
caught well no they were on government
property oh trespass yeah there's worse
crimes yeah
what she did was control all delete yeah
[ __ ] it that's true mike's gonna hit her
up like so i heard what you did oh my
god i told you talk to my lawyers no i
need you for my job
i like your style ladies imagine wanting
to hire this woman after hearing this
mike is there you think it's that bad i
don't think it's bad i mean well if
she's very petty have this person hired
at your company and then you're going to
be like hey so can we talk about your
performance it's going to be fine by the
way you just need them on your side yeah
that's the problem how do you know that
they're not going to turn on you i don't
think she's a [ __ ] i think she's just
petty i'm teddy so let's say she applies
for a job at your gym yeah and then
you're like oh it says you got fire here
uh yeah what happened yeah what happened
i just deleted 17 000 applications
you're hired 200k mike mike goes she's
hired you guys don't believe the second
chances in this group then huh you guys
are just [ __ ] one of those i thought
i wasn't
i believe a second chance is not 17 000
chances i'm still on the fence so i'm
listening to both argument sides
i haven't decided what did she get fired
for deleting all those [ __ ] emails
and [ __ ] no no what is she director
no that's what she did after she got
fired all right well she was she was
locking people out if she got into
arguments oh yes yeah i don't think
that's that bad i really just don't what
if her co-workers are [ __ ] because
she could have unlocked it if that yeah
if the co-worker wasn't as much of an
[ __ ] you're like hey sorry about that
argument i really [ __ ] up like cool
i'll give you access how old is your
business this particular one of the year
i'm excited to see how yeah
we'll be all right
[Music]
you